The solution was found by
another British mathematician
and cryptographer, Clifford Cox.
Cox needed to construct
a special kind
of one-way function called a
trap door one-way function.
This is a function that is easy
to compute in one direction,
yet difficult to
reverse unless you
have special information
called the trap door.
For this, he turned to
modular exponentiation,
which we introduced
as clock arithmetic
in the Diffie-Hellman
key exchange, as follows.
Take a number, raise it
to some exponent, divide
by the modulus, and
output the remainder.
This can be used to encrypt
a message as follows.
Imagine Bob has a message, which
is converted into a number, m.
He then multiplies his
number by itself e times,
where e is a public
exponent, then
he divides the result
by a random number n
and outputs the remainder
of the division.
This results in some number c.
This calculation
is easy to perform.
However, given only c, e, and
n, it is much more difficult
to determine which m
was used, because we'd
have to resort to some
form of trial and error.
So this is our one-way
function that we
can apply to m--
easy to perform,
but difficult to reverse.
It is our mathematical lock.
Now, what about the key?
The key is the trap door,
some piece of information
that makes it easy to reverse
the encryption We need
to raise c to some
other exponent,
say d, which will undo the
initial operation applied to m,
and return the
original message, m.
So both operations
together is the same as m
to the power of e all raised
to the power of d, which
is the same as m to
the power of e times d.
e is the encryption.
d is the decryption.
Therefore we need a way
for Alice to construct e
and d which makes it difficult
for anyone else to find d.
This requires a second
one-way function,
which is used for generating d.
And for this, he
looked back to Euclid.